مشاهدينا الكرام فهو النجم الرياضي
السعودي الاولمبي العالمي
كنت معسكر قبل كده في جده بعد كذا معسكر
خارجي وحاليا جاهز وان شاء الله الوصول
للنهائي ان شاء الله
خلاص هو هذا اليوم وهذا هو السباق وانا
داخل السباق
[موسيقى]
جد نفس الشعور اللي انا كنت احسه من
اسابيع اني بدات احس نفسي اني انا اطير ما
هو انا جالس اجري
[موسيقى]
على طول يعني كان فيها انتظار وانتظار الى
انها تظهر النتيجه في الساعه في وقتها كنا
يعني في حيره انا متاكد انجلو في نفس
اللحظه هو نفس الشعور
الين ظهرت النتيجه على الساعه كان يعني
كانت لحظات يعني بصراحه تخلت التاريخ
وفعلا يعني كانت بدايه قصه ممكن انها تحكى
الاجيال
ولدت في الطائف عام 1971 ميلادي في
المرحله اللي فعليا طفوله كانت في مدينه
اخرى كانت في خميس مشيط الوالد لما انتقل
انتقل بالعائله احنا اخذنا معه من اليوم
الاول فاحنا انتقلنا للمدينه فلما جينا ما
كان في مكان للسكن
اولى الاسابيع سكنا في خيمه
اخد هالوالد يعني من الوحده العسكريه اللي
هو يعمل فيها نبدا يومنا تقريبا من قبل
الشروق فسواء في ايام الدراسه او في ايام
الاجازات نطلع جبل ننزل من جبل نلعب كوره
كل يوم عشان تروح للمدرسه تقطع مسافه
ثمانيه الى عشره كيلو وترجع نفس المسافه
كره القدم يعني كانت كانت وما زالت يعني
شغف للسعوديين وجهني معلم التربيه البدنيه
في فتره بحراسه المرمى تميزت فيها بصراحه
لكن ما كنت يعني اشعر فيها بالاكشن مثلا
انك لما تسجل جول كل الناس يحتفل فيك لما
تصدق كوره ما احد يدري عنك بعدها في
المرحله المتوسطه فكنت احب اجمع الناس
اكون الفريق انا اللي ارتب اللي هي
مباريات ونطلع مثلا نلعب في خارج حدود
الحي
اول ما جيت للنادي كان مدرب النادي اللي
هو المرحوم الاستاذ محمد ذو الفقار الله
يرحمه
[موسيقى]
يعني الامور دائما متسارعه بتقريبا من
السنه الاولى او الثانيه انا بدات ابرز
اتم اختياري للمره الاولى للمنتخب وكانت
هذه الفتره انا خلصت فيها ثانويه العامه
من الفرحه وانا رحت كلمت العائله وقلت لهم
انا اليوم تم اختياري للمنتخب وبطلع معسكر
تدريبي فئتنا ورايحين نقضي الصيف هناك
ورايحين نلعب بطولتين مبروك ولكن
التوقيت اللي تروح فيه للمنتخب لا ابدا ما
تروح لازم تسجل في جامعه في كليه وبعدين
تقدر تروح ابدا ما استسلمت كانت فيها
محاولات فيها دموع فيها مشاكل فيها اضراب
عن اشياء كثر انا كنت اعملها لانه حلم
حياه اي رياضي مثلا انه تقع انه يكون يمثل
المنتخبات فانا قاتلت بشتى الطرق ولكن في
النهايه يعني اخواني اكبر اعلى
فاتتني فرصه المشاركه او تمثيل المنتخب في
هذه السنه دخلت لكليه التربيه الرياضيه في
الرياض الخيار اللي امامي اني ابحث عن اي
طريق مختصر لان احلامي بدات تكبر
في السنه الاولى اقيمت عام 1991 اللي هي
البطوله الخليجيه في الرياض فرحت للبطوله
حامل للعلم مش العلم السعودي اللي هي
الاعلام اللي هو في حفل الافتتاح كل
اللاعبين خصوصا من الفريق السعودي يعرفون
يعرفون مين انا ويعرفوا اني انا الافضل
على مستوى المملكه في مسابقه 110 متر
حواجز وجول البطوله هم كممثلين للمنتخب
وكلاعبي وانا جيت كحامل علم مع طلاب بكليه
التربيه الرياضيه فكان مؤلم للغايه
اخر الليل انا من الزعل من الغضب لما
اختليت بنفسي اخذوني للمستشفى رحت
للمستشفى عمل الاشعه وشاف يعني الحجم عضله
القلب فلما شافني قال انت عندك مشاكل في
القلب مشاكل في القلب من فين جات انا
اليوم لما اعرف اني انا رياضي هنا بدا
يعني يشرح ويقول لا انه يعني القلب
الرياضي دائما خصوصا العدائين يكون يعني
الحجم مختلف
ابدا اشرحها من هذا المنحنى
السنه الاولى اختياري للمنتخب عام
1992 مثلت في العشاري فكانت يعني فرحتي
كبيره ولما كلمت الاهل قلت انا تم اختياري
والمعسكر راح يكون ان شاء الله هذا الصيف
راح يكون في فرنسا فقال لي الحين روح الله
يبارك لك ودعواتنا لك بالتوفيق فهنا كانت
البدايه وكان الصفحه جديده مع بين العلاقه
مع العائله والرياضه وتركيبه كلها مع بعض
[موسيقى]
93 ايضا انا مثلت في مسابقتين مختلفه في
مسابقه الميه وعشره حواجز
ومسابقه التتابع مع فريق التتابع
عام 1995 انا بدات اتخصص في الحواجز
لالعاب القوى يدخل منافسات هذه الالعاب
كانت في بطوله مهمه في ايطاليا تقريبا من
المصنفين اذا ما كنت الاول من مصنف الثاني
او الثالث البطوله فكن الاقرب لتحقيق
الميداليه والاقرب التحقيق الميداليه
الذهبيه لعبه التصفيات كسبت التصفيات
بكل اريحيه دخلت المركز الاول وافضل زمن
في المجموعتين في اليوم الثاني كانت اللي
هو السباق النهائي
[موسيقى]
راح تقدمت على المجموعه 120 130 متر في
السباق
يعني باصابه في العضله الخلفيه
مجبر اني ما اقدر اكمل السباق فراحوا
المجموعه من حواليا وانا والسباق وتوجوا
بالميداليات وفايزين ورافعينا ايديهم وبعد
كذا ياخذوا الاعلام وياخذوا لفه انتصار
عايشتها وانا موجود لكن بين الالم وبين
الحسره واحساس على اني انا خسرت كل الموسم
مش فقط خسرت بطوله
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
96 كانت التجربه الاولى لي على المستوى
الاولمبي فكانت خلال الفتره التدريبيه كان
معسكر نتدريبي في امريكا فكنت انا اتفاجا
اني انا افوز على هذا الابطال بكمالهم
البدني
بحضورهم بتاريخهم بعض الملتقيات يفوز علي
ولكن ايضا يعني حتى فوزهم ما كان يعني فوز
يعني بسهوله انا هناك فعلا انا بدات انه
يعني اشوف نفسي بمنظار اخر اللي اكد فعلا
انه في مجموعه من اللاعبين اللي انا فعلا
كنت افوز عليهم واستطاعوا انهم يتوجوا
ميداليات في اولمبياد هذا المنجز اللي ما
يضاهيه مال او اي امر اخر
هنا انا بدات اعي انه صاحب الميداليه
الذهبيه انه يعامل معامله اخرى وانه فعلا
يعني يكون محقق اسمى ما يمكن تحقيقه في
الرياضه
عام 98 كان القرار من الاتحاد السعودي او
بالاصح من الامير نواب بن محمد اللي كان
يراسل الاتحاد السعودي في هذاك الوقت الى
اني اتوجه لبريكه للتدرب مع المدرب
بعد ثلاثه اشهر الى اربعه اشهر من التدريب
وقبل انطلاق الدوره بثلاثه اسابيع يجيني
اتصال من رئيس الاتحاد
سعودي او كاس المملكه العربيه السعوديه ما
راح تشارك في دوره الالعاب الاسيويه
قرارات ما هو بيدي انا ولا بيدي الاتحاد
ولكن هذه توجيهات
امامنا الا عنا
يعني ننفذ هذه التوجيهات كان الوضع فعلا
محبط انا بدات اجهز وانا اصبح افضل لاعب
اسيوي في هذاك التوقيت في مسابقه 400 متر
حواجز
مؤهل على اني اكون صاحب الميداليه الذهبيه
في البطوله اللي راح تنطلق بعد ثلاث
اسابيع طيب هذا القرار طيب انا وضعي يعني
كلاعب انا الان وجدت نفسي لا خلاص بصراحه
لازم انك ترجع للسعوديه وبعدين فكر كيف
انك ترجع ثاني تتمرن مع المد
لما رجعت للسعوديه فين التدريب من هو
المدرب فكان الخيار المطروح انك تروح
البيشه
[موسيقى]
ما كان امامي خيار الا اني اخذ شنطتي اركب
سيارتي اروح لبيشه ايش المتوفر في بيشه ما
كان فيه بيوت شباب ما كان في سكن ما كان
فيه اي حاجه تذكر لمعسكر تدريبي اللاعبين
الموجودين في بيشه يجوا في فتره التدريب
من بيوتهم للتدريب في النادي او اللي هو
كان مش النادي على قدر انه ملعب التعليم
في بيشه فعلا انا رجعت يعني خطوات للخلف
كثير فكنت كل حصه تدريبيه اشوف انها ما
لها معنى كل يوم انا اروح فيه للتدريب مش
هذا اللي هي احلامي اللي انا قريب اني انا
احققها
[موسيقى]
استمريت في تدريب في بيشه كامل المعسكر
لعبت مع المدرب بطولتين كانت الاولى اللي
هي دوره الالعاب العربيه في الاردن بعدها
تقريبا باسابيع لعبنا البطوله العربيه
الالعاب القوى في بيروت قدرت اني احقق
الميداليه الذهبيه في الحواجز واحطم الرقم
السعودي والرقم العربي في هذا المسابقه
عام 2000 انا رجعت للتدريب في المدرب في
امريكا بعدها طلعنا
جاء وقت السباق كيف جاهزيتي كيف ادائي
التدريب تدريب والمسابقه مسابقه انا قلت
يعني لا تحدي الان مش مع الاخرين تحديين
مع عشره حواجز امامي انطلق السباق معي
مجموعه تعتبر متميزه
لان هي تقريبا الحواجز الثمانيه الاولى
يتبقى لك حاجزين ولكن في المستقيم النهائي
فانا لما وصلت لهذاك المكان انا بدات اشعر
اني انا متقدم على المجموعه
اعرف ان بعدها عندي سباق نهائي اذا انهيت
السباق بهذا المستوى هنا انا بدات يعني
اهدئ بالريدمي
الحمد لله انهيت السباق فانهيت بهذا القوه
بهذا الزمن وانا مهدي الرتم هذا اعطتني
الثقه مهوله انا قدرت اني احقق المركز
الاول واكون اول لاعب سعودي يصل الى سباق
نهائي في الاولمبياد وقدرت اني احطم الرقم
الاسيوي في مسابقه 400 متر حواجز
الكلام او السواليف مع المجموعه في القريه
الاولمبيه بدات تختلف بدات يعني اتكلم
بدات ابتسم
[موسيقى]
ممكن اكثر قلق كنت انا اشعر فيه ان عضلاتي
انا ما تخدمني يعني في الوقت تبدا تستذكر
كل جزئيه مثلا مرت عليك في مسيرتك او في
حياتك الرياضيه خمس سنوات قبل يعني لما
كنت في ايطاليا جاهز للسباق وتجيني
للاصابه في وسط الصباغ
صحيت الصباح في يوم السباق وانا منتشي الى
درجه مهوله خلاص هو هذا اليوم وهذا هو
السباق وانا داخل السباق ما عندي اي هموم
بصراحه كنت افكر فيها في هذاك التوقيت
بالتحديد فلما بدات بالاحماء جد نفس
الشعور اللي انا كنت احسه من اسابيع اني
بدات احس نفسي اني انا اطير ما هو انا
جالس اجري فالمدرب قال لي
يعني اليوم يعني قادر تحسن زمنك قلت له
هذا هو الوقت اللي انا رايح فيه اجري 47
قال لي يعني راح تحقق ميداليه قلت له لا
انا داخل عشان احقق ميداليه ذهبيه
يعني تقريبا في هذاك اليوم في هذاك السباق
كان الحضور الجماهيري تقريبا يتجاوز
الستين الف متفرج والله اني اذكر اني انا
دخلت للسباق ما اسمع اي صوت ما اشوف اي
احد انا ماشي امامي نقطه واحده اللي انا
جالس اشوفها اللي هو هذه الحواجز العشره
انا كيف اجتازها وكيف اصل في هذا المكان
كلاعب اول
[موسيقى]
الشمالي
النتيجه ما اعلنت على طول يعني كان فيها
انتظار وانتظار الى انها تظهر النتيجه في
الساعه في وقتها كنا يعني في حيره انا
متاكد انجلو في نفس اللحظه هو نفس الشعور
انه دائما يعني كل انسان سواء رياضي او
غير رياضي هو يحسب الجانب
الاسوا ما يحسب الجانب الايجابي يعني رجلي
كانت سابقه انجلو ولكن طريقه الحساب
للسباقات في العاب القوى هو يكون على
مستوى الصدر فلما جاء على مستوى الصدر
اجره كان متقدم عن متقدم عني في السباق
فراحت النتيجه لاجل انجرو انه انا فقدت
الميداليه الذهبيه
[موسيقى]
من المملكه العربيه السعوديه الشقيقه
يتزوج بالميداليه القبطيه وهي اول مجال
المملكه العربيه السعوديه واول مجال قبطيه
للعرب
[موسيقى]
جمهور السعودي يستاهل اكثر من كده ان شاء
الله دور الذهب ان شاء الله
انا لما رجعت كانت في جدوله ان احنا
التقينا مع خادم الحرمين الملك فهد الله
يرحمه بالاضافه الى انه استقبلنا ولي
العهد وقتها اللي هو الملك عبد الله الله
يرحمه
في تفاصيل مثلا انتوا لو انك مديت راسك
شوي كان كسبت الميداليه الذهبيه
وكيفك على احساسك
والله لكن لا اعرف انه كنت طبيعي
نلتقي باحد القيادات الشبابيه صاحب السمو
الملكيه الامير محمد العبد الله الفيصل
مساكم الله بالخير
طويل العمر
شاهدتم معنا سباق هذه ايش كان احساسك
اثناء مشاري والله كان ودي حاجتين كان ودي
ادزه شوي
ولا رخي راسك كان خلينا الذهب
[موسيقى]
هو انتهى السباق لكن ما انتهى الموسم
فجمعنا السباق ايضا
بالاجله وبقيه المتسابقين للاسف انه كان
نفس السيناريو كنت انا متقدم وفي اللحظه
الاخيره استطاع العوده انجلو تايلور
هذه الحمد لله
وهذا راح يسهل
مهمه ووجهه نظري في التالق والانجاز
الاكبر ان شاء الله
العالم القادمه في كندا في صيف
2001 ان شاء الله
وعلى راسهم والذي سيضع حدا لمسيرته بعد
ختام منافسات الدوله
[موسيقى]
بحلول رابعه ضمن المجموعه الخامسه في
التصفيات
[موسيقى]
انا في هذيك اللحظه انا قلت انا ببعض عن
نفسي يعني احد لهذه المسيره وانا خلاص
يعني اعتقد اني افكر بحياتي الاخرى خصوصا
اني تجاوزت الثلاثين وحلل عداء السعودي
هذه صوعان رابعا
اول مره رحت فيها الامريكان كانت عام 1994
اول سنه تدريبيه فانا رحت مع المدرب
والتقيت بالفريق والتقيت بالمجموعه ولكن
كان القرار اني انا ابدل مع مدرب اخر عام
95 انا ما رحت لامريكا 96 كان القرار مره
اخرى اني انا ارجع فغيرنا المكان وطلعنا
البطوله 97 انا رجعت للتدريب في السعودي
عام 98 كان القرار مره اخرى اني انا ارجع
تقريبا انا رجعت ثاني للسعوديه البديل
اللي كان بين بيشه بين المانيا بين هذا
التدريب عام 2000 رجعت مره ثانيه
[موسيقى]
قله الخبره قله الخبره مهو ليا انا قله
الخبره كانت حتى للمسؤولين لا تتخيل انه
مثلا ما دخلنا في كل هذا التنقلات
والتبديل وروح وتعال وكان يعني فعلا انه
هذا هو المكان الانسب لهادي من عام
1994 او 96 واني انا استمريت فيها كيف كان
وضعي انا لما اجي على الاولمبيكس اكيد
باجيها لاعب اخر لاعب متكامل لاعب في قمه
النضوج
فسخت اللي هو الحذاء المخصص للجري اللي
يسمى سبايكس وقلت انا هنا هذه هي اخر
محطاتي
والعاب القران كل ما اقولها الان لعبه ما
هي ممتعه لعبه مميته على مستوى التدريب ما
هي ممتعه مش مثل الالعاب الجماعيه او كره
القدم على سبيل المثال انت استمتع بكل حصه
تدريبيه تلعب كوره تسجل هدف تفرح ومن هذا
القبيل لعبتنا لا انت مع الساعه او انت مع
الزمن او انت مع القياس لعبه فعلا تدريبها
ممل قاسي بطولاتها نفس الطريقه انت تعاني
وتعرف انك تتالم في البطوله عشان تحقق
الفرحه الوحيده فيها لما تفوز يعني انت
بكره لما لا قدر الله خسرت او شيء زياده
على الالم الم نفسي
[موسيقى]
جلست مع رئيس الاتحاد
وسالني سؤال قال لي انت الان يعني فين
شايف نفسك مستقبلا في خدمه الاتحاد او في
خدمه الرياض فما كان امامي الا اني اقبل
على اني اعمل في الاتحاد في اللجان
بعدها قبلت على اني اكون عضو مجلس اداره
فعملت في اتحاد اللعبه
[موسيقى]
شيء ممكن انا ما قدرت احققه كلاعب ولكن ما
زلت الى الان يعني انا قادر على اني اكون
في يوم مساهم باي مسمى كان في تحقيق
المملكه سواء فريق او لاعب الميداليه ان
شاء الله الذهبيه على المستوى الاولمبي
[موسيقى]